A random black man who was, according to some,
out for a jog has been shot dead by two white
men who chased after him, claiming he looked
like a burglar that had been in the neighborhood.
The story is a tragedy and there have been
no arrests at this point in time.
Now, I'm not pretending to know everything
about the story.
I'm going to tell you what we believe is the
case so far.
Amide arbitrary, 25 years old.
This happened February 23rd.
It's been months in Brunswick, Georgia.
The video has recently been released.
Arbitrary was running through the still assures
neighborhood.
He was chased by 64 year old Gregory McMichael
and his 34 year old son, Travis McMichael.
Now, I'm going to play some of the video for
you, part of the video of part of the incident
for you.
It is relatively graphic.
Heads up in case you want to skip ahead.
It's about 30, 35 seconds of video.
You're listening and not watching.
You'll be able to see the video on our YouTube
clip or find it elsewhere online very easily.
Let's take a look.
No one has yet been arrested for this, although
it has been more than two months since the
incident took place.
So here is the story as it has now been pieced
together and it is certainly not a complete
story to date.
The MC Michael's father and son, they saw
Carbury as they claim, quote, hauling ass.
That's the term they used.
And they thought that must be the burglar
who's been burglarizing houses in this neighborhood.
So the MC Michaels grabbed a 357 magnum and
a shotgun one for each, got into their pickup
truck and started chasing amide arbitrary.
A third man also joined the chase in their
pickup truck.
They caught up to arbitrary and Gregory McMichael
reportedly shouted at him to stop.
And this created a confrontation of sorts.
McMichael claims Berry started attacking his
son, Travis.
A scuffle ensued, potentially over control
of the shotgun that Travis McMichael had,
which led to a shot being fired and subsequently
a second shot being fired.
Arbitrary did not have a weapon, and he was
shot dead at the scene.
Now, the next step would be, according to
officials, for this to go to a grand jury.
But it's important to understand that it's
not necessary to wait for a grand jury to
make arrests.
And we're gonna talk about that in a moment.
We have a statement from Director Vic Reynolds
of the Georgia Bureau of Investigations of
the Georgia Bureau of Investigation.
And he talks about the case and listen to
the hemming and hawing that's going on here.
I offered our assistance in this matter.
Mr. Darden, our able to connect and speak
about 9:30 last night, and he quickly accepted
our offer and ask us to become involved in
the case.
Some of you may not realize with the GBI can
only become involved in a matter when asked
by the local authorities.
After Ms. Mr. Darden's request last night,
I advised him that we would hit the ground
running this morning.
We've now assigned this case to three of our
experienced supervisory level agents.
They come from two separate regions and a
specialized unit which is located in a third
region.
We've also decided that this case will be
ran from headquarters that will bring to bear
every resource and all the experience this
agency has in resolving this matter.
Our goal in every investigation is to seek
the truth.
So listen, guys, this is on video.
Now, I admit the video doesn't show us the
start of the incident.
And I'm going to talk about that in a moment.
But it's been months.
A lot of it is on video.
This is a huge dog and pony show.
Now, why have there not been any arrests?
I'm going to do the best job I can at laying
out the case for not arresting anyone yet.
OK, now I want to be really clear disclaimers.
I'm not saying this case that I'm about I'm
about to lay out resonates with me.
I'm going to make the strongest case I can
to play devil's advocate.
OK.
The Mic Michaels were legally carrying their
guns.
The 357 Magnum and the shotgun were legally
opened, carried based on Georgia law.
So having the guns with them is not legally
a problem.
They begin to pursue someone that they believe
to be a burglary suspect.
Now, you and I might say, listen, this resembles
a burglary suspect.
It was just a guy who happened to be black.
That this is racism.
There's race that explains what went on here.
That's fine.
It is still not illegal to pursue someone
again under Georgia law who they believe to
be a burglary suspect.
Now, you and I understand that this term burglary
suspect is absolutely crazy.
We're just talking about a guy who happens
to be black.
But I'm trying to lay out a legal case here
so we can see both sides of this.
Georgia law says a private person may arrest
an offender if the offense is committed in
the presence or within immediate knowledge.
The video starts during a confrontation where
there is already a scuffle between arbitrary
and one of the MC Michaels.
Now, again, under Georgia law, if indeed arbitrary
was attacking or trying to take the gun from
McMichael, McMichael would be allowed to use
up to deadly force in that situation.
Now the video starts too late to see how this
all started.
We don't have the story of the dead guy.
We only have the story of the MC Michaels,
who, of course, don't want to be arrested
and charged here.
Now, I want to be really clear.
I believe that these two should have been
arrested and then let the legal system work.
What I am pointing out is that there is a
case some are making for why it's logical
that nobody has been arrested yet.
But I have a different perspective.
We have a system of justice.
People are innocent until proven guilty.
I'm not saying anything about the legal guilt
of the McMichael.
That would be for a court to sort out.
What I am saying is that this is clearly meeting
the standard for it to be in the legal system.
If the racial circumstances were reversed,
if this were two black men with guns or three
men in a pickup truck who identified a guy
that resembled the burglar only in that he
was white and the burglar was believed to
be white, the two or three black men would
have been arrested and charged.
And it would be up to them to mount a legal
defense at this point.
They might be guilty legally.
They might be not guilty legally.
It would be up to the state to prove it in
a court of law.
But they would have been arrested and charged
by now in this case.
It's been more than two months.
No one's been arrested merely on the say that
the victim resembled a possible burglar in
that he was black.
This is laughable.
Now, again, you don't have to take a position
on guilt or innocence to critique the situation.
You have people on the right saying the McMichael
is have the presumption of innocence until
proven guilty.
And that is exactly right.
They do.
There is no argument from me on that.
But nothing has happened to even put them
in a position of being tried.
And that is what doesn't make sense when you
think about how this would have gone down
if the circumstances were only slightly different.
If you disagree with me, if I'm missing something,
by all means, let me know.
I want to get it right.
That's what matters.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Quick break right back after this.